I am with sweat so it's a great baby
name hey guys it's Tuesday and it's
grace it's time to talk back to you
let's start over on tumblr
but bxg new person to very first afro
that do not know when a new person
comments on one of my social media
outlets I praise the crappin on them and
welcome to the its Christ family touch
your face on the sides part bxg what's
that stand for heart big extreme
genitals is that why you works for fans
all the time huh is this so
am i projecting boomer brother might to
sell my soul to an order to receive
Grace's love that item is discontinued
what a [ __ ] baby to person in person in
person what a [ __ ] baby more like what
effect Adler is on where the name tag is
so stupid because toddlers are
inherently very very dumb tangent also a
very great baby name boy Gracie's tumblr
it's just all pictures of her I'm not
complaining I know I've had this
conversation with varied Anna that are
blogs on tumblr are just the most
self-serving spaces it's just our photos
and gifs and I it's real it's it's gross
now it's gonna stop
Sarah's come smile new person a person
in person stairs - and smile more like
Sarah's boned for a while you've abroad
should be watching the Montreal
Canadiens game but yet I can't stop
watching Griselda videos they're called
the Montreal Canadiens
I mean that's great
possibly is great it's like the New
Jersey Devils you tell me which team is
more self-aware it's a baby a new person
in person in person so babe a more like
save a save it always save your work
because computers can shut down you
before like very something had our
lactose sensitivity hit her in her
mid-20s it's my body trying to copy her
because I don't want this make it stop
there's no God and if there's a God he's
sitting up there sucking down breathe
and giving no shits because he can
digest that cheese she needs us Becca's
world's new person to person to person
Becca's world's more like Becca clearly
believes in multiple universes and so we
should all respect her thoughts opinions
decisions but also keep us safe distance
boom boo-boom I seriously just spend my
day watching grace Helbig videos you
excrete at some point excuse me I need
to leave nails go to stop Chuck Peterson
new friends new person to person Chuck
Peters and more like could that be a
more generic boy human name I feel like
I'm getting catfished which unless it's
fried I don't really want it you boys
realize Grace has got her teeth shaped
so lame grace but I guess it's alright
because you live in LA
um no I didn't get my teeth shaped I
hope that reshapes your opinion of me
Senna boating define diverse new person
sent a boat anymore like send the body
to me no I usually send pick him back
human boom dammit you made me laugh
while I was wearing a face mask that is
the most first world problem I've ever
heard
I apologize here's some gold extra blue
numbers numbers numbers and extra blue
like estrogen makes you blue periods you
brought those are some sad looking
bloody marys come on you can't get it
right yes
London I love you but your bloody marys
S&D bloody out there bloody awful sorry
well that's it for talking back to you
guys I don't think you had a great time
here and excuse me tiny bird I don't
know
that put I made new ones by the way
because the other ones
are so gross but they lasted five and a
half months so god bless you
oh there's hair stuck in it uh